so initially I plan to make a video
about all-new all-different Deadpool but
instead what I want to do here is make a
video about Deadpool vs Thanos and the
reason why is because this story is
amazing and I'm hoping that at the end
of the next several videos even if
you're not the biggest fans of Deadpool
you'll have at least had a good time
so Deadpool vs. Thanos was written by
Tim Seeley who was also responsible for
guardians of the galaxy the best story
ever and is actually an in continuity
story taking place prior to Secret Wars
and the collapse of the multiverse like
many Deadpool stories were not given an
explicit time which is to say that it
takes place between two particular
issues but because most of his comics
are standalone we can probably get away
with saying that it could take place
between any of the events of his comics
from 2010 to 2011 now as we get into
this well one thing I want to do is set
the stage for this story by having a
discussion on the relationship between
Deadpool Thanos and Mistress death the
reason why is because this story will
largely draw on existing information
from previous stories and so it makes
sense that we simply need to provide a
little bit of context beginning with
Deadpool his relationship with mistress
death actually came during a read column
with Deadpool annual in 1998 now if
you're looking for a more comprehensive
discussion regarding this story as well
as the idea of Deadpool mistress death
and Thanos regarding their whole love
triangle I have a video on that that
you're welcome to check out but the
overarching theme here is that during
his time under the Weapon X project
which granted him his healing factor
waited formed a relationship with
mistress death who promised that the two
would be together when he finally died
however at the moment when he was
supposed to cross over his healing
factor kicked in keeping the two
separated from one another now the other
half of this equation is Thanos and is
one of the most well known villains in
comics thanks to stories like Infinity
Gauntlet and Marvel the end as well as
his highly anticipated appearance in
Avengers infinity war a major part of
his characters development has been his
pursuit of mistress deaths love where
his early appearances in the Captain
Marvel comics as well as the Thanos
quest and Infinity Gauntlet depicted
this as an unexplained aspect of his
character with Jason Aaron's 2013
miniseries Thanos rising the
relationship between the two dated back
to his childhood with his actions being
guided by death to fulfill her own
sadistic desires during this story
Thanos has spent decades seating his own
children all year turn around and kill
them all travel to his homeworld and
wipe out his own race due to the
manipulations of death all of which went
towards creating an unrequited love
which she would never return now the
love triangle between mistress death
Deadpool and Thanos came into full swing
in the 2002 four-part miniseries titled
fear
for freek where Deadpool faced a
prospect of dying once again after being
blown up with only his hand remaining at
the end of the story it was revealed the
Thanos had Kirsten with immortality out
of jealousy that Deadpool was bumping
uglies with mistress death and so as a
result dead food simply healed from his
hand and returned a life and so as we
get into Deadpool vs. Thanos the story
actually picks up in a place called
Saint Cynthia Island appearing for the
first time in this story the island is
owned by Doctor Doom and was created as
a tribute to his mother as a bit of a
refresher in our video on Victor Von
Doom we had discussed that his mother
was a Romani living in Europe at the
turn of the century and had sold her
soul to the demon Mephisto and return
for knowledge on black magic where she
was eventually killed dooms early
exploits and learning about magic and
power were all rooted in his drive to
free his mother's soul while he was
unsuccessful and she was destined to
spend eternity in the demon realm of
Mephisto this island represents his
attempt to keep her memory alive
even if only for himself and so a
Deadpool arriving on the island and
knocking on dooms door Victor is treated
to a shot in honor of his arrival
unfortunately instead of the shot coming
in the form of a wine or a nice glass of
cognac instead it comes in the form of a
12-gauge shotgun presumably having been
assigned the task of killing DMO that
were not really told why the indication
seems to be the Deadpool simply wanted
to prove that he could do something none
of the Avengers could this is
highlighted in the fact the Deadpool
actually calls Stark Industries and
after reaching the receptionist but
learning that neither Tony Stark North
or present leaves a message stating that
he was successfully able to kill the
actual Victor Von Doom rather than one
of his doom bot clones however in the
midst of his conversation the story
starts to set up when Doom comes back to
life now when Deadpool asked doom how it
is it he is alive
Victor provides us with a dying
experience which is something that we
haven't really seen before but what I
mean here is that while various
individuals like the original Captain
Marvel and Jean Grey have died the in
comic depiction of their death is
usually just them approaching a light
light what Doom tells us is that his
experience was it when he died he felt a
sudden rush of pain saw darkness
followed by his childhood home and then
was suddenly returned to life and so
with doom attacking Wade with a blast of
energy
Deadpool celebrates that with his death
she'll be able to be with his Bey
now for those who don't know BAE is an
acronym for the phrase before anyone
else meaning that mistress death is his
main squeeze now picking up in the realm
between life and death we join deadpool
as he wears a combination of the
greatest mustache and afro ever seen by
human eyes setting the mood by opening a
bottle of champagne and putting it on
ice Deadpool is met with the arrival of
mistress death on the opposite side of a
mirror now what this section of the
story does is tell us that the reason
why Doctor Doom had returned to life
after Deadpool shot him is because that
misters death is missing and was unable
to take doom to her realm at this point
we jump to a man named Black Talon and
to be honest this guy is really just
crazy more so than anything else the
real name of Black Talon is Desmond
Drewe and he exists as somewhat of a
cult leader in the Caribbean while he
isn't really able to demonstrate powers
of Voodoo on any scale that matters
his mother momma limbo is an
accomplished voodoo priest capable of
resurrecting the dead hence the reason
why you see zombies present the reason
why Deadpool is here is explained when
he states that following the death and
resurrection of doom he came under the
belief that black talent or his mother
had cast some kind of curse on humanity
they kept them from dying
however black talent reveals at both
Thor and dr. strange had come looking
for him under the same suspicions with
Thor actually tearing his house apart
now where black talent admits that he
doesn't know any sort of magic that dark
or strong something that writer Tim
Seeley does with this story is also
bring up the notion that Deadpool is
cursed what's interesting about this is
that up until this moment
Deadpool never knew that Thanos had
cursed him with immortality instead
every time Deadpool died and returned a
life he simply just chalked it up to his
healing factor and so as a result and
for reasons that only makes sense to him
Deadpool connects the dots and comes up
with the idea that Thanos had kidnapped
mistress death resulting in the
inability for anyone to die now we're
Black Talon offers to use his powers to
trace where it is at Thanos is gone
Deadpool agrees but has also developed a
plan of his own according to Wade the
plan comes in four stages
Stage one involves black town using his
magic to locate Thanos
Stage two requires a black tile and uses
magic to spear Doctor Doom in the
direction of the Avengers to keep them
from trying to figure out why people
aren't dying stage three involves
Deadpool acquiring a ship from Cable and
stage four ends with the death of Thanos
and
Poole making sweet sweet love to
mistress death now we're black Colin
states of defeating Thanos will be
difficult to the fact that he's so
powerful
Deadpool makes the case that because he
routinely outsells Superman due to his
popularity while Thanos is just a
miserable grump Deadpool is guaranteed
to come out on top because that's how
the story is written at this point we
join Deadpool as he's getting smashed
into a bloody puddle by Thanos according
to the mad Titan his hatred for humanity
extends to the fact that humans by
nature consider themselves to be the
center of existence at the same time
Thanos has grown tired of Deadpool and
his antics getting in the way of Thanos
has pursued a mistress deaths affections
as a result he ends the curse placed
upon Deadpool which had kept him
immortal and in the process quite
literally beats him to death with his
bare hands now picking up again in the
space between life and death which is
now being depicted as a massive ice
landmass Deadpool is visited by mistress
now the second time and her efforts to
plead with him
to save her now the cool thing about
these depictions of the space between
life and death is that it's entirely
reflective of the person's own views at
the time they died in this instance
Deadpool having died at the hands of
Thanos coupled with mistress death
missing exemplify itself in that this
place is barren indicating the Deadpool
himself beliefs things are hopeless this
is compounded on when he makes a
statement that he believes he failed
mistress death but because she has such
a strong attraction to Deadpool she
makes the case that he has to find a way
due to the fact that despite his life
being surrounded by darkness and that he
lives a life of murder he always finds
his way back to the light and that he's
brave and going to go to the limit for
the things that he cares about at this
point the story transitions to a couple
of events that will come to the fruition
in the second and third issues but what
we do here is we jump back to black town
because his island is largely inhabited
by zombies they've apparently been
meeting in secret and have come to the
conclusion that because no one is able
to die the living are now on par with
the undead since no one can die as such
they begun to pick it demanding equal
rights and treatment now while this
isn't extremely important the
significance of this moment comes when
the scene is met with the arrival of
Ajax as Deadpool's arch-nemesis and
introduced during the Joe Kelly run from
1997 with issue number 14 Ajax's arrival
comes due to his pursuit of Deadpool
from here we jump to the science station
of nowhere in starlings bar as a funny
aside Stalin's bar is actually named
after jim Starlin who had made the
cosmic operand marvel comic's popular
due to Infinity Gauntlet but within the
bar itself is one of the blood brothers
as well as a guardians of the galaxy as
one half of a duo of this serf Thanos
for a time during his early appearances
the current blood brother had lost his
twin during a fight with Drax the
destroyer as a result with the
inhabitants of the universe unable to
die the belief of the blood brother is
that his twin may return but because he
asked ties with Thanos and is likely
aware of where Thanos is located he's
attacked from behind by star-lord with
the intention of finding Thanos his
location now joining back with Deadpool
and Thanos himself we get some pretty
important information regarding Wade's
ability to die what we're told is that
when thousands had previously cursed him
he'd removed Deadpool's ability to die
from the control of mistress death and
bound it to Thanos himself as such
Thanos is the only one who can kill
Deadpool what this means is that it's
not impossible for individuals to be
transitioned to the realm of death the
issue here is that mistress death
herself can't be the one to do it and so
to this end when Thanos had beaten way
to death he used his experience as a way
to monitor the conversation between Wade
and mistress death to gain a better
understanding of what was happening but
also to inform death that he had killed
Deadpool to prove his affections for her
while mistress death ultimately chose
Deadpool over Thanos due to the fact
that she had appeared to wade in her
pleads for safety and also referred to
him as her one true love
Thanos makes the statement that he
intends to gain the affections of
mistress death by rescuing her however
because ACLU's to her location rests in
the mind of Deadpool Thanos needs him to
achieve his own goal and so offering
Deadpool a handful of jewels as payment
for his assistance Deadpool ultimately
turns the offering down in favor of the
fact that the mission to save mistress
death is a personal one which you will
happily undertake for free with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and let me know down in
the comments section what you guys think
about this story so far and I will catch
you guys later
whose